all right I didn't plan on doing a video
about this I was gonna do a video
reviewing the character when the DLC
came out which I believe is August 9th
but just now I was like I still have my
initial thoughts on the situation so now
we're gonna talk about it and that is
the new DLC character announced for
Mortal Kombat this past weekend
initially we had scarlet then Kenji then
rain and now we have Freddy Krueger
isn't yeah that Freddy Krueger and as
far as DLC characters could have gone it
is pretty much perfect scarlet was the
first she's pretty good but she's a
little slow for me it seems like her
special attack she liked rubs back and
then does it and that cost time Ken
she's a badass so you can't go wrong
with Kenji rain I still haven't gotten
yet because as I said in my Mortal
Kombat game review no one gives a [ __ ]
about rain he might be DLC later but
seriously in Mortal Kombat trilogy did
anyone really care about rain and I
still hold to it although the character
video where he shows the gameplay for
rain for this Mortal Kombat it shows him
doing all sorts of sick combos so he
looks like he's a badass fighter I just
don't like Ryan all I know is if it was
borracho I hate that character too but
it turns out to be Freddy Krueger and
this is awesome I showed my friend he's
a big Freddy Krueger fan he's like I'm
getting the game now there's no way you
can really [ __ ] about Freddy Krueger
being in mortal combat bitching about
that is like bitching about any aspect
of the movie the Christmas story you
can't do it the only gripe I've heard
and I kind of agree with is that this
Freddy Krueger's the Jackie Earle Haley
Freddy Krueger from 2010 why not have
the Robert Englund one I don't know
maybe they're pushing for a sequel if
there's an easy fix for that just give
Freddy Kruger an alternate costume that
you can pick and have it be the Robert
Englund Freddy at that point everybody
wins no one can gripe because no human
being on earth can gripe about Freddy
Krueger being in mortal combat he's
perfect he's dark he's sinister he's
evil his character trailerware shows him
doing the combos just the gameplay
footage you know dude he's crazy
although he looks like he can be a cheap
bastard so I'm sure a lot of people
playing online but they're gonna get
frustrated with Freddy fans my other
frustration with the Mortal Kombat
Freddy gameplay trailer is it shows both
his fatalities let's do but don't do
that let us find it out and the other
thing that I know the Freddy purists are
gonna [ __ ] about is he has blade gloves
on both his hands Freddy he only
actually has one blade glove hand so
there is that other than that it's
Freddy Krueger in mortal combat I'm
gonna play the [ __ ] out of that
character it seems that the Mortal
Kombat team and Ed Boon is said before
that he likes to and crossovers he's
always wanted to do crossovers which is
why I did the Mortal Kombat vs. DC
Universe thing something tells me this
is gonna work out a little better for
him just saying they've been smart for
their crossovers for this Mortal Kombat
I mean Kratos perfect for Mortal Kombat
Freddy Krueger perfect for mortal calm
makes me wonder what else they have in
store so I want to hear your thoughts
what are your thoughts of Freddy Krueger
being in mortal combat and if you want
any other character in mortal combat as
a crossover DLC character who would it
be comment below let me know xbox people
if you want Marcus Fenix and more will
combat then you write Marcus Fenix below
if I see John Madden you know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]